give a sense of which communication
style suits you best audio video written
word
well then if that's the case you should
do video and then transcribe think about
the double benefit I have New York Times
bestselling books and have never written
a sentence of it it's all out of my
mouth video transcribed to book even the
last book because I did during covid
like my team visited me at my apartment
I just talked we just filmed it all and
now you have much more content if you
film it that you can use in other places
so I would definitely lean into the
video and transcribe it to the written
work even if you directly are doing an
article speak it and let that be the
written thing now all of a sudden you're
at 12 a week instead of 12 a month